to start the recording so I do want to
let you know that we will be recording
this webinar and later on the recording
will be shared with all of you and those
that were interested to participate in
register for the program to the hands-on
biomedical data science this online
program is a course that combines
user-friendly processing and machine
learning methods designed for high to
put big biomedical data and what we'll
cover in this program is a combination
of practical skills how you can develop
practical skills that you can later on
use to address your own research and
biomedical challenges that you're
working on we'll be talking about the
various questions typical for the
biomedical industry and we'll also be
talking about how we can address the
problem of big data where computational
resources and video tools need to be
combined in a seamless way to help us
address biomedical challenges quickly in
the program we'll use a variety of
resources and we'll talk today about how
to get started how to get set up and
also how to look at a variety of data
sets that we'll be using throughout the
program
again for those that are joining right
now
welcome and we look forward to getting
to know you and we're also expecting
that we will have regular sessions where
we can meet and address any questions
that people might have and help
everybody get started with hands-on
biomedical data science so that you can
be ready to solve biomedical challenges
and analyze large data sets and we'll
talk about a few different aspects of
that today so in this program in this
short introduction we will go through
some of the logistics of the program
itself how to get started how to get
ready for the program itself and start
installing some of the useful tools that
will be utilizing throughout this
program so the goal of this program is
to understand how processing big data
analysis using machine learning
visualization and different aspects of
data analysis all fit together and are
critical for our ability to understand
biomedical challenges in the context of
these high-throughput data sets now
typically we will look at the biomedical
data challenges from the perspective of
precision medicine and we'll talk a
little bit today about some of those
challenges and some of those topics the
program is also designed to show a
variety of different tools will use as
at the TBI own foot platform which is a
multi omics integration environment
where you can process explore mine and
analyze data and we'll look at also some
of the other tools that will help you
improve visualization technique
understand how data can you know and we
will also look at how we can easily
review the data in tools like Excel
which is also a powerful spreadsheet
application so welcome everybody again
and in this introductory session we'll
review some of these topics and make
sure that everybody can get started so
let's first of all talk about the
schedule the onyx logic biomedical data
science program is going to be divided
into five different parts so the first
four parts are listed right here we will
start by introduction to the program
where we'll look at what high throughput
data experiments are what are some of
the challenges and opportunities
associated with high throughput data
such as next-generation sequencing but
also other types of high throughput data
and we'll look at onyx technologies
genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
epigenomics so a variety of different
onyx but also include non
next-generation sequencing data for
example screening of molecules testing
different drugs on cell lines imaging
technologies and other we'll also look
at some of the challenges and
opportunities in precision medicine as
well as permeated with molecular data
and drug discovery then we'll go into
exploratory data analysis so when we
talk about exploratory data analysis
we'll be discussing how we can use
statistical properties of data that help
us summarize and compare a variety of
different assets we'll talk about the
challenges in preparing data structuring
the data so that it's accessible but
also making the data comparable so that
we are not looking at the noise but
we're really comparing signal that is
biologically relevant we'll also look at
a variety of tools that we have like
probability correlation and Association
what do they mean how do we quantify
them and how can we use that in
different stages of our data analysis
well then look at the common data
visualization
techniques in Excel and our because we
would like to use those to work with our
datasets and be able to interpret and
what we are finding the third portion of
the program will be dedicated to data
mining mining large data sets usually
involves utilizing unsupervised machine
learning techniques where we are going
to be looking at prominent trends and
variation that we can compare and
identify both in big datasets but also
the features of the datasets that we'll
be looking at we'll also look at how we
can use very specific methods like
principal component analysis
dimensionality reduction and how do we
prepare the data using filtering
normalization log transformation and
other methods then we'll move on to
classification in the context of
discriminant analysis when we want to
compare a variety of datasets and
identify how they are different we can
use a variety of machine learning tools
typically these are going to be
supervised machine learning tools where
we have an annotated data set using the
annotation we will be able to train a
model model that can later on be used
for prediction in other words it can
help us identify how the data set and
that we have trained the machine
learning method on can help us further
on identify the trends in a new data set
so we'll cover a variety of different
methods discriminant analysis decision
trees random forests support vector
machines and even talk about deep
learning but after this basic training
any one of you is going to be ready to
apply these techniques to a project and
that is a critical part of the program
so we encourage all of you to first of
all understand some of these methods
understand how they work together and
then start thinking about how can we
apply
these two new questions that you might
have and to some of the exemplar
projects that we already have on our
platform first of all the schedule
itself is listed already on our site so
there you can see all of the different
sessions so I went over kind of the
bigger five distinct portions of the
program but if you're interested to see
each individual session you can go onto
the onyx logic page and you'll be able
to see all of the individual sessions
and also we have already a number of
exemplar projects that you can choose
from and all of those projects are going
to be available to all of the
participants of the program so I'll go a
little bit into how to register and how
to make sure you have access but here's
the code that you can use to get in
access to any other projects that we
have total fall right here so let's talk
about the registration and how to get
started with the program so using this
link and I'm just going to paste this in
chat so please make sure that you can
see that using this link you can get to
this page on this page you have to be
logged in so you will see your profile
image right here and then right here you
see today session program overview as
well as all of the following sessions by
date and you can register for that
specific session so look through some of
these sessions make sure that you
register for the upcoming ones so that
you can join those and you can get
notifications about the materials those
for those sessions down here below we
have a forum or essentially a stream of
updates from the participants of this
program so you can look at everything
that everybody is doing and the goal of
having an updated profile is so that
this becomes a network
you can leverage in the throughout the
course of the program and after that as
well so you can see that each person has
a profile you can click on that profile
and you will be able to see the
background of that person potentially
social media links like link to their
LinkedIn profile or something like that
and also see their activity so the
reason we have prepared this
organization page is so that all of you
can get to know each other and we can
easily share updates for example like
this one where we pout important links
and encourage people to ask questions or
even answer those questions right here
also you have a number of links right
here above help you navigate the various
parts of the you can see the curriculum
page so I just go right here real quick
the curriculum page lists out all of the
events by date so you'll be able to see
that today we are doing program overview
and gives you a kind of a breakdown of
some of the topics that we'll be
covering then you can see that we will
go on and talk about next generation
sequencing and various onyx technologies
we will talk about summary statistics
and what are those statistical
properties data visualization for
exploratory analysis factor regression
analysis is how we can leverage factor
regression regression and correlation
between factors that affect what we see
in the data visualization and network
analysis dimensionality reduction
clustering decision trees etc
essentially up until we reach this stage
when we start talking about projects so
all of these online resources are going
to help with the program itself as it
continues but you can also start looking
at some of the courses associated with
the program itself especially
you can look at this tab right here
called courses where we have already
added a couple of courses that you can
get started with so I'm just going to go
to this tab and here you can see that
once you enroll in the course you will
see a progress bar and this progress bar
shows you how far along on are you in
this course and also you will be able to
see some of the courses are paid but
again total fall is that code that you
can gain access to any of the online
resources for free
throughout the program itself so let's
review so far what we've covered one you
have to be registered on the edu website
you have to also register for the
program so once you get to this link if
you're not a member of this program
there's going to be a yellow button that
says register for math membership and
once you register for the membership
you're a part of the onyx logic data
science program then complete your
profile when you complete your profile
please add your profile image add social
media links add some background
information about you so that we can
offer I'll learn about you and we can
then help you identify topics that might
be more relevant or interesting to you
and also assist you in other ways
review the schedule of the program so we
used to how we have this curriculum tab
or we have a short summary on the main
page you can also reach out to us and
we're happy to share with you the
syllabus for the whole program that
shares a little more in detail what will
be covered in each session after you
review the events register for those
events so click register for the event
or you can also register for all of the
upcoming events and keep track of your
progress so we'll talk a little bit more
in detail what that means because we use
a point system that helps all of us
understand where we are and helps us
align the
progress of the whole group with what's
actually happening so that we don't run
too fast and we don't move too slow here
are a couple of good examples of people
that have already completed a profile
and you can see how easy it is to
understand who is who and start
interacting with those people so you can
see that the person has a profile image
they we assign different levels based on
your progress so essentially the more
courses you complete the higher your
level we have a point system that
essentially tracks all of your activity
on the platform including pipelines that
you run including courses that you
complete replies to forum posts etc and
you can also see this badge that tells
us that this person is a registered
person of a program so little background
on the onyx logic programs we run seven
different onyx logic programs throughout
the year this is one of them focused on
data science but we also have programs
dedicated to genomics transcriptomics
metagenomics epigenomics and many others
including organizations and universities
that run the program internally so here
for example you can see the Louisiana
biomedical research network so this
person is a member of that program now
you can also see what courses the person
has been working on and how far along
they are you can see the completed ones
and it's important to complete a course
so that that is registered but also you
can see the person's projects that
they're working on and activity in
general ok if you have any questions
about how all of this works we welcome
your questions please post them on chat
we'd be happy to answer them throughout
this session or later on you can also
see a chat box on the website so you can
contact us through there
so what we are trying to set up here is
a process that helps you get from where
you are in advance so that you will have
a a sense of accomplishment you know
what you have achieved you know what
kinds of topics you have covered and
also prepare you for real projects and
datasets that you can analyze on your
own as a part of this environment we
have set up a leaderboard and you can
see some of the top performers on the
site you will become a part of the
leaderboard once you cross the threshold
of 3500 points you have to be registered
for the Onix logic biomedical data
program to be a part of the data science
specific leaderboard and we'll talk a
little bit more about some opportunities
that come with that
we'll be introducing you to our network
if you're looking to develop a network
of contacts around the world that helps
you access to to job opportunities
research opportunities and understand
other conferences where you can present
your research and others so that is one
aspect of it the other aspect of it is
really being a part of competitions that
we will be launching in the next several
weeks one of them is going to be related
to this program specifically to the rep
reducibility of research that you've
done that you do using computational
methods and I'll talk about that in a
little bit okay so now we've covered
some of the aspects of the program
including the schedule how to get
registered how to get started with a
variety of resources that we have on the
platform
now let's talk about the hands-on aspect
of the program itself so the hands-on
aspect of the program is tied to those
different tools and resources that we
started talking about in the beginning
so let's start talking about each one of
those one-by-one
first of all the T by omen for platform
now some of you already have access to
the platform you've requested access or
you are a member of the site or one of
our programs for those of you that have
not after this session we will be
sending you additional emails with your
credentials so if you still do not have
access to the T bio info platform you
have to request that access from us or
wait for an email that will be coming
out for those that have registered for
the Onix logic data science program now
this program this program is covered on
this link T bio info you can learn about
the platform within for the platform the
research and educational tools that can
help you get started is on the edu that
T - bio that info and then the
analytical platform itself is on server
dot T - bio info so let's go there and
thank you for Team for posting that in
chat so if you look in chat you will see
the link to the platform so let's just
go over what is going on on the platform
what it is and why it is being included
in this program so once you gain access
you should be able to see your email
address is your login and you should
receive an email with the password do
not necessarily use the password that
you have for the educational site it's a
different account and you can see that
once you're logged in you will see a
number of different sections available
on the platform so briefly there is a
section on next-generation sequencing
data there is a section on mass spec
data structural biology data and then
data integration or modeling in the
context of this data we will talk about
all of these different sections
including processing of data analysis of
this data and visualization of this data
and we'll talk about the connection
between the various properties of data
that we are analyzing we
they're biomechanical interpretation if
you already have your login information
if you're already in there you will be
able to follow along with the
demonstration that I'm doing now by
using the demo pipelines throughout the
program we will not be using the demo
pipelines will be actually uploading our
own datasets and we will give you access
to larger datasets that is going to be
challenging to upload and download if
you're just working from home so we're
going to try and make sure that anyone
that's participating in this program can
practically analyze these datasets and
we'll explain the process of gaining
access to the platform as well as those
datasets as we move along throughout the
program so we talked about the platform
and what it is and I want to talk a
little but a little bit about the
challenge of these big data sets that
are unstructured so as you know
next-generation sequencing is a process
of shotgun sequencing in other words a
variety of different portions of DNA or
RNA are transferred into a sequence of
nucleotides and then our challenge is
combining them together and aligning
them to a reference genome so that we
can for example quantify gene expression
so to quantify gene expression you need
to align those reads to the reference
genome and then apply a variety of
different tools to identify gene
locations locations of potential
alternative alternative splicing events
that generate different isoforms and
then quantify those so that we get a
table of expression for those that are
joining now how do I request access to
the analytical server so those of you
that have already completed your
registration for the Onix logic program
you will be getting a mail later
day with your credentials for those of
you that have not completed please
complete the registration to the program
by going on the registration link and
then we will be sending you the
credentials if you just want to explore
the platform and understand how it works
you can also request separately by email
a demo version of the platform so let's
take a look at the demo version and
understand how it works once you're
logged in and you see your login
information right here you will see that
by clicking the drop down arrows you get
access to some demo pipelines so we can
go into this cell line pipeline and what
is important to understand here is that
this is a an interface a visual
interface that allows us to connect a
number of different scripts and
algorithms with with each other into a
single pipeline so this is what I want
to demonstrate but I want to also for
everybody to understand that each button
here represents an algorithm and you can
learn more about the algorithm as the
popups come up and you will see that in
a second so let's get started this is a
section dedicated to next-generation
sequencing analysis of gene expression
or transcriptomics so transcriptomics
involves several different steps
pre-processing mapping and then
quantification of expression levels this
could be achieved using several
different pipelines and we'll start with
the most simple one we will go from
start to a couple of pre-processing
steps then mapping on transcripts and
then quantification you can click on ok
and now you can see that the platform
will suggest some next steps this is a
demo so in the real world this will be
based on the data that you are upload
and some of the settings that we have on
the platform so I'm not going to go into
detail about each one of these steps
because we have a whole session
dedicated to processing of
next-generation sequencing data
but I want you to notice that you have
an explanation of each one of these
algorithms and for most of them there is
also a link to the publication now as
you go through you will notice that
there's also input and output files that
you can take a look at to understand how
each section works as we map on
transcripts and prepare the level of
expression the output will be a table
where we see genes and samples and for
each sample we have a quantified level
of expression you can read more about
transcriptomics in this series that
includes transcriptomics 1 2 3 & 4 and
you can see the link right here so you
can click on this link and this link
points you to some free resources that
anyone whether you're a part of this
program or not a part of the and not a
part of this program can start working
so transcriptomics 1 will talk about
processing the data transcriptomics 2
we'll talk about differential gene
expression transcriptomics 3 we'll
introduce some of the dimensionality
reduction clustering and classification
algorithms and transcriptomics 4 talks
about cell transfer balance so you can
see that the platform educational
resources are closely integrated and
this close integration allows us to both
help advance the whole program so that
everybody covers the same material but
also keep track on where the challenge
is are and where do we need to spend
more time so the platform again look at
some of these links the platform will
help you process large data sets not on
your computer this is all done in the
cloud so you access the platform through
a web interface meaning that you can do
the analysis anywhere and it's not going
to stop you from doing other things but
also we have prepared some
sample data sets that you can start with
play around with the demo pipelines but
also look at some example or projects
that we have prepared for you so you can
create there a variety of different
pipeline and some pipelines very simple
and some pipelines are going to be more
expanded like this the goal of the
platform is to help process large data
sets but also to do it in a very
reputable way and I'll talk about this
aspect of repres ability towards the end
which is a very critical issue arising
in a variety of different domains but
especially critical for those that are
interested in more industrial level
research excuse me the second part of
this program is going to be focused on
our in our studio so we will use some of
the scripts that are both on the
platform and then we will look at them
in a more expanded way in your own our
studio environment on your computer so
to do that and this is important for all
of the participants especially you have
to download our download our studio
install them on your computer and test
that everything is working so here are
some links let me go back
so here are some links where you can
start this process and please be ready
for the next session with a downloaded
with downloading our studio and our and
making sure that everything is working
ok so I pasted those links depending on
your on your operating system Windows
Mac Linux you can install the right R
and then one this your R is installed
and configured go ahead and install our
studio the free version of course and
you will see there that you have a whole
environment that helps streamline the
process of data analysis and
visualization and we'll talk about how
we can leverage a lot of the different
resources that are prepackaged called
libraries that will allow us to do
complex things in a very easy way and
now I just want to mention how these two
are connected right so we talked about
the t-value in for platform we talked
about are in our studio and you're
probably familiar with these but I'm
going to just show you how these two are
connected so if we go back to the
platform we looked here at how to
process large scale transcriptomic data
now once we have that table of
expression this is where a lot of time
is you return to other tools to start
visualizing data performing statistical
analysis of data training your machine
learning models etc so under data mining
right here we have a couple of sections
that we'll be using a lot throughout
this program so for example we can go to
unsupervised analysis and I want to just
demonstrate how we will connect the data
that we have from analysis of let's say
raw fast queue data all the way to data
visualization in our whenever you are
actually using the platform not in demo
mode
an actual educational mode you will be
able to upload files and here we will be
using next-generation sequencing data
let me quickly find that data set okay
so every time for a program and yes
result the beginner can also take this
course all of this is going to be fairly
simple so what we will do in every
session is we will provide you with a
dataset that we will be looking at
throughout the program so as you can see
it's a very user friendly interface all
I did was I upload a dataset a txt table
now after I press on continue you can
see that every step of the way I have
some guidance so I can understand what I
am trying to do and I can have I have
here three different options I can do
visualization using principal component
analysis clustering using a variety of
clustering methods and do network
analysis so in this case let's try with
something simple we will use principal
component analysis to simplify the data
set that is complex because of the
number of features that it has
in using simple graphical inputs to
generate the analysis but also download
the art script that we can later on can
modify once I run my pipeline
you will see that the pipeline has
started and I have 1% because it has
started right here and I can see what
are the steps that I took in my pipeline
so obviously the more complex the
pipeline the more difficult it's going
to be to remember every step of the way
and what parameters were selected so
let's take a look at how this helps us
create rep reducible pipelines once I go
to
my pipelines I will see a list of all
the different pipelines that I ran and i
can see that my pipeline is processing
so you can see here that it's static and
to see the progress I actually just need
to refresh the page I will also get an
email notification to my email when the
pipeline has completed beyond that you
can see here that simply hovering over
this Seymour I can see all of the steps
that were used and what kind of data was
used in the pipeline after the pipeline
has completed I can also see a full
report about my pipeline so for example
if I look at let me see if I look at
this pipeline right here if it's not
compressed I will be able to see the
report so I mean just by the way for
educational pipelines you will notice
that every few weeks we compress the
pipeline's to save space ok so let's
take a look here so you can see this is
what a report looks like it tells you
when the pipeline was run and when this
report essentially was generated what is
the name of the pipeline what is the
time it took to complete every step in
CPU time and in real time what are some
of the files that were generated etc and
you can see here a breakdown of this
information right here now this is very
important for your analysis to be
reproducible because once you start
working on a real project you will see
how each project takes some time several
weeks often and so you will have to go
back and understand what did I do
did I normalize my data that I just
process raw data what combinations of
factors that I include here and what
were the settings for each one each step
of the way so now you can see them
when this pipeline is complete it says
done 100% so let's go in here and let's
take a look at some of the output files
that this pipeline produced you can see
here that the pipeline produced a number
of different outputs including a text
file a zip file and a plot a PDF plot so
let's quickly take a look at this plot
to understand and what it means okay so
we have a PDF here okay and the PDF
looks like this so the PDF shows us dots
force samples and you can see here some
separation between obvious groups so we
will see that this PDF is actually
produced by an R script so let us
download this R script really quickly to
take a look at what's inside this R
script has the input data it has the
call that you would use in your terminal
to call this script and then it also
actually has this script so then we can
open the script in our studio and take a
look at what essentially the script does
so that we can understand not only that
we have an input and an output but we
also understand how that input and
output has been done so this is our
studio and in our studio you can see
that some libraries were loaded you can
see that some arguments were defined you
can see that we have loaded the data so
you can see that we are reading the
table and loading the data and we're
also looking differently at the headers
at the rows and we check for different
names and then you can see how we have
the number of scripts that actually
prepare the
and we run principle component analysis
and principle component analysis is
simply a dimensionality reduction
technique that helps us look at the data
from the best perspective that explains
the most variability in our data set now
before I go too deep into this I'm not
going to confuse you right now because I
think we need several steps of the way
before we actually jump into our studio
but this is just to demonstrate that you
can go from a pipeline on the T by
landfill platform and then expand your
capabilities in terms of visualization
and more specific types of analyses so
essentially the platform becomes as a
springboard for you to start developing
your own analysis and understanding the
steps that you are making okay so when
we talked about how to get started and
here's just an example that we will
actually look at each step of the way
and try to improve this principal
component analysis we will look at
different are scripts that do clustering
we will look at our scripts that run
things like random forests or create
specific visualizations like heat maps
box plots etc all in the context of
combining large-scale data processing
and preparation quick data mining and
then looking at specific questions and
we'll get to that in a second here how
do I a beautiful question for this type
of a dataset so we'll look at how we can
actually go beyond the platform and
create something a little bit more
custom in preparation for this type of
analysis I encourage all of you whether
you are participating in the program or
you're just learning about a program to
take this free course it's called bio
data science so if you go to the to the
educational site and if you're a part of
the program you will see it right here
if you're not
the program just go to courses and just
look at all the courses you'll find
these courses and here let's just take a
look at what this does this is a very
good tutorial that was prepared to
introduce everybody to some of these
topics how to set up our studio how to
load the libraries how to check that
you've got at the rent libraries how to
set up your environment so you know
which directory you're working in so all
of the basics up to the point of loading
the data running principal component
analysis and modifying some of the look
and feel of your results so again if
you're interested in this program you're
wondering how is this going to be a
practical hands-on program for me this
is a good example project that you can
go through or a course re that you can
go through understand how it will work
so in the sessions we will do this kind
of guided demonstration and then in your
free time whenever you have the time you
can go in and complete some of these
descendants another good course to look
at is this introductory call a course
called machine learning for biomedical
data if you're not familiar with machine
learning and you don't know the
difference between supervised and
unsupervised machine learning what is
clustering what is what is
classification all of that is briefly
covered in this introductory course ok
somebody asking here for a link to the
bio data science free course so let me
just paste it here in chat so this is
the link ok
so once you get a sense for all of these
different tools and what we are doing
and how we are doing one of the question
is well what are we doing what is a
meaningful project what is a meaningful
question for me to be able to address
and that is I would say a critical
component of this program I think there
are plenty of courses out there that
teacher about our and the different
machine learning methods but what is
often lacking is how do you ask the
right question how do you understand the
problem in the context of the data that
you have and how do you choose the
analysis methods to be able to answer
that question so let's take a look at an
example when we talk about biomedical
data we're talking about somebody that
is a biologist or a clinician looking at
the data and changing the way they
interact with a situation for example a
patient so it could be somehow linked to
this iceberg idea you have on top
clinical data which is essentially
clinical symptoms of a disease somebody
comes in something hurts there's a grow
something on the surface the challenge
is to link what's on the surface with
what is below the surface and it's
important to understand that oftentimes
that is going to be a lot more deep than
what's on the surface so on the surface
you might have 20 different features for
example cell count or you know different
elements that you can detect in blood or
even visually but underneath you have
this molecular detail what's happening
at the cellular or sub cellular level
what genes are expressed what
modifications in the DNA in a tumor are
there and then the question is how do
you link those things to the phenotype
that we can interpret so we'll talk
about how this is done but specifically
we'll talk about it
using practical examples so this is one
of the papers and if you've been around
through some of our programs you will
see that we use this example very often
it won't be limited to this example but
I think it's a good example that is
impactful in terms of what it
demonstrates but also not as complicated
and some of the other one ones in terms
of the amount of biology that you have
to have in your background and in terms
of technical background that you have to
have so let's take a look at this this
is essentially an abstract from a paper
called modeling precision treatment of
breast cancer right so this is just an
example and you can see down here that
we have this link let me paste that in
chat sorry okay so we have this paper
and this paper let's just quickly
untanned the highlighted words help us
understand what it's about so we're
going to be looking at molecular
profiles to identify features that can
predict therapeutic response and select
optimal predictors now this is going to
be a demonstration of molecular path of
biology that integrates onyx level
information and help select most
predictive molecular feature sets for a
clinical classification in terms of
diagnosis and selection of treatment so
you can see that in the results the
orange color indicates some of the
technical methods and the yellow color
indicates some of the conceptual level
for us to understand what they were
doing so they used least squares support
vector machines random forest copy
number aberrations mutations gene and
eyes a form expression so some of the
datasets are described here some of the
methods are described here but I think
what makes a lot of sense is what we can
see right here visually in this visual
abstract so you can see that they took a
number of breast cancer cell lines
two different drugs molecular profile of
those cell lines and integrated that
information to be able to predict
response to drugs but also they compared
it to the Cancer Genome Atlas so we can
see that as an example of one of the
challenges that could be addressed in
the context of biomedical research and
industry so let's take a look at breast
so here we have the mammogram and the
mammogram has this dot right here right
so this is phenotypic information this
is something external and we intuitively
say okay well it's a tumor now it's a
tumor that we need to categorize we need
to give more definition to this problem
so how can we give it more definition we
can for example look at the source
tissue where did this tumor originate
from and we have these different names
for example invasive lobular carcinoma
is a name that describes this tumor from
the standpoint of which organ or what
types of tissue it originated from
looking further at the tissue we can
actually take scans of that tissue and
we can stain it using
immunohistochemistry to identify
expression or different proteins but
when we talk about immunohistochemistry
we're actually having limitation with
the number of proteins that we can look
for so here you can see classification
of subtypes of breast cancer using a
variety of different proteins that are
expressed or not expressed in a specific
tissue this is an example of molecular
look at the same data if we use multiple
expression of genes or a gene panel we
can categorize the samples looking at
their gene expression profiles so here
you can see how we can classify
different subtypes of breast cancer
using p.m. 5050 genes that help us
understand
in a more precise way how we can
categorize these different subtypes so
these types of projects is what we will
go into and as you can see here we have
a variety of data sets we have images we
have protein expression we have gene
expression and we will try to link that
to clinical questions what is the
survival how will they respond to drugs
how do we assign them to a specific
group of patients so let's talk a little
bit about what types of questions are
there that we can answer using data
analysis patients stratification so
patient stratification has to do with
subtypes has to do with identification
of groups well-defined groups but also
linking that to survival and recurrence
and patient stratification can prom I
always see the link here to risk
stratification what is risk
stratification is organizing our data in
groups that can help us estimate the
level of risk the higher the level of
risk the more aggressive we can assign
the treatment for that and also we can
combine different elements of treatments
that we have available to address what
we consider to be the drivers of that
risk we can also look at responders
versus non responders right so when we
talk about selection of treatment we can
look at whether a person will be
responsive to treatment or is there some
for example mutation in a protein where
the molecule binds that will help us
understand that that person is not going
to be responsive to a treatment this is
especially important in the context of
clinical trials when we have clinical
trials one of the biggest challenges is
selection of patients how can we select
patients that will respond and or not
respond to very specific treatments that
we are trying to test or combinations of
treatments right now we also need to
understand how we can use our molecular
features to build predictive signatures
so
this is called biomarkers or gene
signatures for example we can look at
gene signatures that can help us in
predicting the outcome of treatments
that can help us understand what will
happen far far away in the future for
example five or ten years from now we
will look at target discovery how do we
understand when we analyze this like
level data how can we understand how
different factors interact with each
other to identify where are those
critical points where we can intervene
and that's called the target which gene
can we target which protein can we
target can we silenced a gene can we
block a protein interaction what can be
done we'll also talk about early
detection if there's a consistent
process that drives the development of
disease can we early on detect that that
process is starting and can we also see
the precursors of certain processes that
we know eventually lead to an outcome
that we want to prevent or even know
that it will happen this includes risk
so we will look at germline mutations
that can be associated with risk and
we'll look at also molecular profiling
that can help identify the level of risk
ultimately predictive analytics it has
to do with machine learning because when
we look at training a data set once we
have labeled our data and we've prepared
our data we can use this data to predict
something that will happen 2-3 years
before it ever happened and the more
reliably can predict that the more
valuable the machine learning method
they're more valuable the analysis that
we ultimately come up with so we'll talk
about predictive analytics in the
context of this type of clinical and
molecular data next time when we meet
we'll start talking about nation
sequencing and onyx technologies so
we'll talk about how we can take raw
fast queue datasets how can we take
genomic data like whole genome sequence
whole exome sequencing whole
transcriptome sequencing or metagenomic
sequencing how can we take those
different types of raw data and process
them structure them so that they are
ready for analysis so that's going to
happen September 18th again at the same
time 9:30 to 10:30 all of you are
invited to join and hopefully that
before this next session you have
already started in written progress with
that list you have registered you have
completed your profile you've gained
access to the server platform you've
gained accent you've installed the tools
that we will be using including our and
our studio you've opened up Excel use
tried loading in some data in Excel and
maybe try to create some kind of
visualization so you're familiar and
we're ready to go forward I want to also
briefly mention what this program will
give you so this program will cover
methods for high-throughput data
processing analysis and visualization
and can help you apply these methods to
address clinical research and
pharmaceutical challenges in the context
of projects it's a very project driven
program that will start from thinking
about what is the challenge and how do
we solve that using data analysis
methods it will help you design prepare
and plan your analysis and make it
impactful the challenges associated with
data analysis and ultimately how to
mitigate the risk that your analysis
will not be effective or will not be
clear how to focus how to clarify the
problem statement how to prepare and
plan for something that might take
several weeks in advance we'll try and
help you potentially build up a whole
portfolio of projects and announce this
example so that when you're talking to
your lab manager to your PI or planning
your own project you're thinking of it
from experience and you can demonstrate
your experience in specific projects and
will help understand biomedical research
and read publications critically
anything this
very important when we look at these
illustrations when we look at
publications at the analysis results
that others have published you saw how
we were looking at those keywords and
we'll cover each one of those concepts
so that next time you look at them it
all makes sense you know each one of
those words what they mean why they were
used and what alternatives are there to
some of those methods and finally we'll
for those of you that qualify
essentially participation here is key
that you join all of these sessions the
point system will help us understand who
is performing well in the program and
you can get a certificate of
participation that will be something
that you can include in your CV post on
LinkedIn etc so this is a summary of the
Onix logic program a little bit of where
we're going to be starting from we
talked about the schedule we talked
about the logistics we talked about some
examples of the hands-on activities
talked about some projects that we'll
talk about and finally if you have any
questions now would be the time to ask
any specific you know questions that you
might have or in general if you would
like to know about our team about our
programs we have a lot of other programs
that are ongoing and so please go ahead
and now you can post your questions in
chat or also feel free to unmute
yourself and please introduce yourself
if you would like to to ask in questions
directly so how long is this new course
and how long will it go all of our
programs are around three months so as I
showed in the beginning we will have
five different
sections of the program so let's take a
look where you can find this information
so if we go to if we go to the
organization page so I'll just paste the
link here again and I want to go over a
little bit about the schedule again if
you go to the homepage of this
organization page so you can see you can
see that right here you have upcoming
events so we started today 16th of
September and then on the 18th of
September we will talk about
next-generation sequencing and this is
just this week and then as you continue
to scroll you will see these dots that
show up on dates all the way to the 17th
of October by the 17th of October we
will be done with the basic part of the
program after that we will focus on
projects which means that you will get
one-on-one feedback on your project
selection you will get access to data
sets that have been already prepared
with some level of tutorials included
that you can start a project on your own
and develop your own question around
that data set and around that problem
statement or you can just identify a
meta-analysis project where you can look
at publications and understand what
others have done with some project so
that you can think of your own challenge
ok so if you want to have a detailed
curriculum you can click right here on
the tab and there you will see all all
of the dates
so again just scroll down and you will
see all of the dates and all the
individual events and at the end as I
mentioned we will transition to projects
so the full program will be around three
months so per team thank you for and
d'arco thank you answering the questions
about our studio this is an important
question because of course you do have
to have the updated version of our and
you also have to make sure that it works
so what I suggest is
click on some of these links that we
have in the chat and start installing
our in our studio and to test that
everything is working properly if you go
right here to courses make sure that you
check out this course called bio data
science so bio data science will help
you test that everything is working
properly and it gives you some some
example that you can actually
practically work through ok so if there
are any more questions feel free to post
them on chat and yes of course yeah so
way we will be going through the
training is we will show you what
libraries and what packages demonstrated
using is that as you make the setup on
your computer you will be able to test
it first to make sure that it works
because obviously there will be a lot of
variation between how it's set up on
your computer from somebody else that
might be using a Mac or Windows version
and so what we want to make sure is that
we will address the conceptual questions
and demonstrate practically that it
works and then you can look into how to
make it work on your computer and we can
schedule even a one-on-one session to
help you get through that so the
question here is how much is a
participation certification so we'll be
happy to email you that information the
list price is 200 dollars for the whole
program
obviously we have some discounts for
students and others so please reach out
to us directly and we'll send you that
information now about the packages there
was a question thank you Darko for
answer and that as well we'll walk
through a lot of the packages will
obviously use some data analysis some
machine learning packages visualization
and we'll talk a little bit more about
which packages and why we are selecting
throughout the program okay so I suggest
that we make this program again the next
session that we will have is going to be
September 18th before September 18th
please follow through the process that
we discussed here register update your
profile make sure that your you've got
access to all of the tools if you have
any questions we would be happy to
answer you we will start talking about
next-generation sequencing data
processing in our next session on
September 18th and then we will go in
how to visualize summarize and explore
some of the datasets that we have put
there Sylvia is asking link for packages
so we do not have a comprehensive list
of packages that we will be using we
will start with a set of packages that
you will find in the again so to get
started it would be very useful to get
started with this principal component
analysis example and then in the example
you will see some of the packages that
we start using there and then we will
expand from there I mean there will be a
whole list so if that's something that
you're interested in identifying a list
of packages that we will go through we
can probably put together a list and
send it to you so feel free to reach out
by email or otherwise so if you have any
other questions please let us know by
email you can reach out to us through
the
chat on website as well and if you have
not gotten your access to the server
platform but you have already registered
wait for those emails they will be
coming later today thank you again for
joining today it was great to get to
know some of the participants that are
planning to join us and if you have not
completed the registration you would
like more information about that please
reach out there are some email addresses
right here in chat team mohit and we
will be looking forward to seeing you
next session which will be on next
generation sequencing data processing
thank you